GILLIAN: MARK MEREDITH FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THANKS SO MUCH.
LELAND.
LELAND: GOVERNORS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE TAKING VERY
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO SPIKING
COVID NUMBERS.
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR PETE
RICKETS CONTINUES TO LEAVE MOST
OF THE DECISIONS UP TO THE
CITIZENS AND THEIR BUSINESSES.
HE JOINS US FROM OMAHA.
THANK YOU, SIR, WE APPRECIATE
IT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LELAND: LOOK AT THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE NOW BECAUSE
SO MUCH OF THIS IS ECONOMIC AND
THE BALANCE BETWEEN HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC HEALTH.
NEBRASKA UNEMPLOYMENT RATE 3%,
NATIONALLY 6.9%.
HOW MUCH OF THAT IS DUE TO THE
FACT THAT YOU’VE ALLOWED
BUSINESSES TO CONTINUE TO STAY
OPEN AND MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS?
>> WELL, I THINK A LOT OF IT,
CREDIT GOES TO NEBRASKANS WHO
ARE WORKING HARD AND THAT’S
PART OF WHO WE ARE, WE HAVE A
GREAT WORK ETHIC HERE.
OUR KEY INDUSTRIES ARE
AGRICULTURE AND MANUFACTURING
AND THOSE HAVEN’T BEEN AS
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC AS
MUCH AS SAY THE SERVICE OR
ENTERTAINMENT ECONOMY.
AND SLOWING DOWN THE SPREAD OF
THE VIRUS AND LETTING PEOPLE
LIVE A NORMAL LIFE.
LELAND: I REMEMBER WE HAD YOU
ON AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC AND WORRIED ABOUT THE
SUPPLY CHAINS AND WE KNOW THAT
NUMBERS ARE SPIKING IN NEBRASKA
AND AROUND THE COUNTRY.
ARE WE GOING BACK TO THE
SITUATION WHERE WE MIGHT HAVE A
SUPPLY ISSUE FOR MEAT AND OTHER
PRODUCTS PRODUCED IN NEBRASKA?
>> NO, KNOW THE AT ALL.
WE TOOK STEPS IN THE SPRING TO
WORK WITH OUR FOOD PROCESSING
PLANTS TO CHANGE THE WAY THEY
OPERATE.
WE’VE PUBLISHED A COVID-19 MEAT
PROCESSORS HANDBOOK, FOR
EXAMPLE, HANDLING AND MASKS AND
SPACING, AND TRAINING AND ALL
OF THAT AND WHAT WE’VE SEEN
WE’VE BEEN ABLE TO MANAGE THIS
IN OUR FOOD PROCESSING PLANTS.
FRANKLY, IT LOOKS BETTER THAN
THE POPULATION AT ALL.
IN NEBRASKA OUR CASES ARE DOWN
25% IN THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
AND HOSPITALIZATIONS ARE DOWN
17%.
WE’RE HOPEFUL WE’RE OVER THE
HUMP NOW.
WE STILL HAVE TO MANAGE IT, BUT
THINGS ARE GETTING BETTER.
LELAND: THINGS ARE GETTING
BETTER PERHAPS IN NEBRASKA, BUT
ISSUES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
A NUMBER OF GOVERNORS AREN’T
TAKING THE APPROACH THAT YOU
ARE ESPECIALLY RELATES TO WHAT
BUSINESSES THEY ALLOW TO BE
OPEN.
LISTEN TO THE EXCHANGE ON CNBC,
BIG BOX STORES, PLACES LIKE
LOWE’S AND HOME DEPOT AS
OPPOSED TO RESTAURANTS.
>> A LOT OF RESTAURANTS FOUGHT
BACK AND THEY DON’T HAVE
PROBLEMS AND THEY’RE OPEN.
>> YOU DON’T HAVE TO BELIEVE
IT, BUT LET ME SAY THIS YOU’RE
DOING A DISSERVICE TO THE
VIEWER BECAUSE THE VIEWERS NEED
TO UNDERSTAND.
>> YOU’RE DOING A DISSERVICE TO
THE VIEWER, YOU ARE!
YOU ARE!
>> I’M SORRY, I’M SORRY, IF --
I WOULD LIKE TO KEEP OUR
VIEWERS AS HEALTHY AS HUMANLY
POSSIBLE.
THE IDEA OF PACKING PEOPLE INTO
RESTAURANTS.
>> I THINK OUR VIEWERS ARE
SMART ENOUGH TO MAKE THE BESTS
ON THEIR OWN.
>> IT’S COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
THINGS.
LELAND: IT BRINGS UP A
PHILOSOPHICAL DIFFERENCE AND
POINT.
AND WHY IS IT THAT YOU VIEW
THAT NEBRASKANS ARE ABLE TO
MAKE DECISIONS ON THEIR OWN
THAT PERHAPS IN CALIFORNIA THE
GOVERNOR THERE DOESN’T SEEM TO
BELIEVE THAT HIS CITIZENS ARE
EITHER SMART ENOUGH OR CAREFUL
ENOUGH OR RESPONSIBLE ENOUGH TO
MAKE DECISIONS ON THEIR OWN?
>> WELL, I MEAN, ONE OF THE
GREAT THINGS ABOUT OUR COUNTRY
IS THAT WE HAVE THE STATE THAT
CAN MAKE DECISIONS AND THEY’RE
CLOSING TO THEIR PEOPLE THAN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULD
BE.
SO, YOU GET LEADERS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE MORE RESPONSIVE TO
THEIR PEOPLE AND MAKE DECISIONS
BASED UPON WHAT’S RIGHT.
LELAND: PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
LARGELY ALLOWED GOVERNORS TO
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS
WITHOUT PUTTING HIS HAND ON THE
SCALE VERY MUCH.
DID A LITTLE IN THE BEGINNING.
SINCE THEN HAS NOT.
ARE YOU WORRIED THAT A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MAY TAKE A
DIFFERENT APPROACH AND YOU’RE
GOING TO BE FORCED WITH MAKING
TOUGH DECISIONS IF FEDERAL AID
DOLLARS ARE DIED TO CERTAIN
COVID RESTRICTIONS?
WELL, I THINK THAT’S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THE FUTURE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION COULD CHOOSE TO
DO.
THING THAT WOULD BE A MISTAKE
FOR THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION UNDERSTOOD
WHEN IT COMES TO MANAGING THE
EMERGENCIES IT’S UP TO THE
STATES NOT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
LELAND: REAL QUICKLY, DOES IT
WORRY YOU THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MIGHT DO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT HOW YOU
WOULD RESPOND IN A SITUATION OF
A NATIONAL MASK MANDATE OR SOME
KIND OF A, YOU KNOW, POWER OF
THE PURSE MOVE BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION?
>> WELL, WE WOULD CERTAINLY
WORK TO CONVINCE THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION THAT THAT IS NOT
IN THEIR BEST INTEREST, THAT
IT’S NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE COUNTRY OR THE STATE TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
I MEAN, AGAIN, I’LL POINT OUT
UNDER THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
THEY CROSSED A LINE WITH REGARD
TO THEIR AUTHORITY NUMEROUS
TIMES AND WE TOOK THEM TO COURT
AND WE’RE VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
SUING THEM TO PREVENT OVERSTEP
OF THEIR AUTHORITY AND YOU
KNOW, IF WE HAD TO DO THE SAME
THING, WE WILL DO THAT AGAIN.
LELAND: STAY TUNED, PERHAPS THE
BEST WAY TO SUM THAT UP.
GOVERNOR, WE APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE TIME ON A SATURDAY.